[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEEVANA HEGDE: Hi,
everyone, I'm Jeevana Hegde.
JOLENE TEO: And I'm Jolene Teo.
JEEVANA HEGDE: And we're
both customer engineers
at Google Cloud.
JOLENE TEO: And we're very
excited to share with you
the launch of the second phase
of our Google Cloud Technical
Guides for Startups, a series of
videos for technical enablement
to help startups to
start, build, and grow
their businesses
successfully and sustainably
on Google Cloud.
JEEVANA HEGDE: Our
mission begins with you.
And we're invested in building
your business successfully
with innovative technology and
holistic support from Google
Cloud.
Hence, whether you're in the
early stage of product market
fit, or you've just received
your next round of funding,
we're here to help you grow.
JOLENE TEO: With the
successful completion
of phase one where we
create a series of videos
to help beginners as well
as early stage startups that
might be in their
pretrial phase to build,
manage, and deploy new
applications onto Google Cloud
from start to finish.
We're delighted to launch
phase two, the Build series.
JEEVANA HEGDE: This
series is designed
to help startups
launched on Google Cloud
to optimize and scale their
existing deployment to reach
target audience.
This is an initiative to help
you build on Google Cloud,
and also understand how
other startups are leveraging
our products and solutions.
JOLENE TEO: And we're
very excited to show you
the launch of our brand
new website, which contains
many useful resources
for startups,
such as our on-demand videos,
as well as our resource
handbooks the companies
setups as they start,
build, and grow on Google Cloud.
To add on, these handbooks
have links to many resources,
such as hands-on labs,
documentation, articles,
and many more,
which can help you
to aid your learning as
they go beyond the topics
that we cover and you can
leverage them to the fullest.
We will continue to update
these resource handbooks
as we embark along the journey.
JEEVANA HEGDE: In
this Build series,
we're navigating
through a whole trail
of topics on Google Cloud.
We kicked off with
this launch video
to give you an overview
of what to expect
from the Build series, which
builds upon the Start series.
We have the link to the
Start series playlist linked
the description box below.
We would suggest you
navigating through
that if you're new
and are just getting
started on Google Cloud.
JOLENE TEO: And in
our second video,
we'll be sharing with few
more details about our startup
programs that are designed to
help you as you build and grow
your business.
And following that,
we'll be diving
into a series of data
videos, beginning
with understanding Firestore.
JEEVANA HEGDE:
After which, we're
also diving into data
analysis with BigQuery,
a popular product
amongst our customers,
and you'll find out why.
Following that,
we'll show you how
you can use your Spark
and Hadoop clusters faster
with Dataproc.
JOLENE TEO: And look into how
you can manage your processing
pipelines with Dataflow, as
well as data visualization
with Data Studio.
JEEVANA HEGDE: And
then, [INAUDIBLE]
do another hot topic of
technology, machine learning,
where we'll be understanding
and using ready-to-use machine
learning APIs, and
understanding how
to build your own models
with Vertex AI, our umbrella
platform for any
machine learning product
JOLENE TEO: We'll then further
look into API management
and how you can manage
your API with Apigee.
We'll then do a security
deep dive, and last but not
least, go through Cloud
Tasks and Cloud Scheduler.
JEEVANA HEGDE: That will be a
wrap up of the Build Series.
And from there, we will move
on to a final Grow series.
We are thrilled to be working
alongside you on your startup
journey to explore concepts,
step-by-step guides, and use
cases across industries.
JOLENE TEO: Up next in the Build
series, in our second episode,
we'll be sharing with you
more about Google Cloud's
very own startup
programs designed
to support your startup as you
build and grow your business.
This includes, firstly, a broad
overview of the various startup
programs available.
JEEVANA HEGDE: The
Google for Startups Cloud
Program for funded
startups up to series
A, providing
business, financial,
and technical support.
A Migration Incentive Program
for later-stage startups
looking to offset
the cost of migrating
cloud services and
infrastructure to Google Cloud.
JOLENE TEO: And with
that, that's a wrap.
Please like and
share this video,
and don't forget to
subscribe to this channel
as well to stay updated
with our series.
JEEVANA HEGDE AND
JOLENE TEO: tight
and we'll see you
on the other side.
[MUSIC PLAYING]